Season 5 brings big changes to Lucifer's world,
with one of the most intriguing occurring
after Luci and Chloe take their relationship
to the next level and discover his powers
have dramatically changed.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'll be revealing the hidden secret
from Season 1 that explains why Lucifer and
Chloe's powers transformed in Season 5.
Spoilers ahead, so take care if you're not
caught up.
There are some strange goings-on with Lucifer's
mojo in Season 5, the crucial moment being
the morning after Luci and Chloe finally sleep
together,
when Lucifer suddenly discovers that Chloe
has acquired one of his superpowers and can
mojo him:
"What do you truly desire?"
On top of that, later that day Lucifer finds
that he seems to have lost his own mojo:
"Niels, tell me.
What do you truly desire?"
"Is this the way you people solve crimes?"
But in the final episode, after he becomes
invulnerable again around Chloe, he discovers
his mojo's returned.
"If I still had my mojo, I'd just ask,
'What is it you desire?'"
"I want to be a dancer."
For a full understanding of what's going on
here we need to go back to a discussion Lucifer
had with Linda in the first season
when he was trying to understand why Chloe
was the only person he knew who was immune
to him:
"Why is she able to refuse my charms?"
"It's not that you're afraid that you don't
have power over Chloe.
It's that you're afraid that she has power
over you, but..
..people don't have power over us.
We give it to them.
You have to take your power back."
We can see how this applies in Season 5, when
Lucifer is repeatedly annoyed that Chloe has
seemingly taken his power away.
"What do you desire?"
"I..
want my mojo back."
Which is why when Lucifer's mojo returns in
the eighth episode, it's likely because he
subconsciously took back his power and stopped
feeling so insecure.
As co-showrunner Joe Henderson said in an
interview with Variety, for Season 5 they
"wanted to find a way to physicalize Lucifer's
insecurities.
And the mojo became an excellent opportunity
to do that."
Another good example of Lucifer's insecurity
or anxiety about this issue is how he went
running to Dr Linda for an impromptu therapy
session straight after discovering that Chloe
could mojo him.
Henderson's comments also tie in with the
running theme in the series that angels can
self-actualize,
which was particularly evident in Season 4
when Lucifer took on a more monstrous appearance
and grew bat-wings because of his self-loathing.
Indeed, Luci's white feather angel wings returned
as soon as he overcame those feelings and
began to accept himself for who he is. and
realised that Chloe did too.
By the way, ironically, it was during that
same conversation with Linda in Season 1 that
I mentioned earlier,
that Lucifer came to the conclusion he could
solve the problem of his powers not working
on Chloe by sleeping with her.
"So you understand?"
"Yes.
I need to have sex with her."
"Uh...
no, uh, that's not what I said."
"No, no, no, you're a genius."
Little did he know that when this eventually
happened, the result would be the exact opposite:
the temporary loss of his mojo.
The next big change in Luci's powers comes
in the Part 1 finale when he discovers he's
now invulnerable even when he's physically
near to Chloe.
The moment occurs just after Dan shoots Lucifer,
and Chloe who was in the same room at the
time, is distraught and assumes the worst
may have happened to Luci.
But then he gets up completely unharmed and,
delighted with the new state of affairs, shoots
himself again.
"Yep, invulnerable!"
Because he's an angel, Lucifer normally can't
be killed or hurt by ordinary mortal weapons.
However, from the fourth episode of Season
1 onwards, the series established that whenever
Chloe was nearby, he could be injured, and
he's even died twice in the show so far, although
those deaths have always been temporary.
So, how did Lucifer regain his invulnerability
around Chloe?
Well, for the answer, let's go back to the
moment just before Dan arrived to shoot Lucifer.
Chloe had just suggested to Luci that because
she could mojo him, it meant for the first
time that he was opening up to her.
However, notice Lucifer's reaction as he begins
to understand the implications of that.
"I think I may have dropped my guard."
And as Chloe goes off to freshen up, a realisation
dawns upon Lucifer about something she told
him previously regarding one of Amenadiel's
theories.
"He thinks that...
you choose to be vulnerable around me."
"I think he might be right."
And Dr Linda pointed out to Chloe earlier
in Season 5 that Lucifer is
"unfathomably narcissistic, utterly terrified
of intimacy,
and sabotages everything good that ever happens
to him."
So, in that short time between Chloe walking
off and Dan arriving, it seems that Lucifer
made a subconscious decision to be invulnerable
again around Chloe.
And Lucifer's return to invulnerability around
Chloe also answers why he wasn't injured in
the slightest in the show's pilot episode
when he was shot at point blank range while
very close to Chloe.
This Season 5 development seems to confirm
the theory that
because Lucifer hadn't yet developed a full
emotional connection to the detective or insecurities
in that first episode,
he was still invulnerable around her.
As for Chloe, she fears this change means
Lucifer doesn't love her any longer:
"Now you're invulnerable all of the time,
doesn't that mean you're no longer choosing
to be vulnerable with me?"
Now, Michael has obviously amplified this
fear in Chloe, but even though Lucifer is
now invulnerable again
"Think of me as your human shield.
Or "Devil shield," rather."
it's evident that he still has feelings for
her when he goes to say:
"Chloe.
I lo--"
Lucifer using Chloe's real name rather than
"Detective" is an important call back to that
major moment in the Season 4 finale when he
confessed his love for her.
"My first love was never Eve.
It was you, Chloe."
So, the real answer as to what's going on
here may be that Lucifer has decided that
emotional vulnerability with Chloe doesn't
have to lead to physical vulnerability around
her.
In other words, he's got his former insecurities
in check.
As Amenadiel told Chloe,
"You're the only mortal who sees him...
for who he truly is."
Because she's immune to Lucifer's mojo, she
sees him for who he truly is rather than reflecting
onto him her own desires and wishes.
And that allows Lucifer to see the good in
himself, in other words, that he's more than
just a cipher for people's desires and a punisher
of their sins.
Interestingly enough, some advice Dr Linda
gave Luci in the first season turned out to
be pretty pertinent to all this:
"Sometimes we need to lose something before
we can understand its value.
When angels fall, they also rise.
All you have to do is embrace all that you
are."
Now, what about Chloe's new mojo powers in
Season 5?
Well, so far it seems like they only work
on Lucifer.
Neither she nor Luci were able to mojo the
opera singer Niels,
and Chloe believes her power only appeared
to work on Mario the vocal coach because he
was a "Hot Tub High School" fan
and he simply responded to her because he
was "star-struck".
"What do you desire?"
"To tell you anything you want to know."
Curiously, there was also an incident in Season
4 where it seems like Chloe might have already
acquired Lucifer's mojo:
"Why did you desire the files on the drive?"
"Because I didn't want anyone to know what
I had done."
However, it's likely that Chloe was piggybacking
off Luci's mojo which was going wild at the
time,
given that all the guests at Lux were coming
up to tell him their desires even without
him asking them.
And that moment was likely also some foreshadowing
for what the writers had planned for Chloe
in Season 5.
Intriguingly, after learning she was a gift
from God, Chloe hoped it meant she had some
powers herself:
"Do I have any powers, or...
anything cool?
I don't know, laser beam hands, something?"
So, in the future could she acquire some more
of Lucifer's superpowers?
For example, if she became immortal like him,
this would resolve the problem that as a human
she's destined to die,
while Lucifer will live forever, though it
would leave her with the problem of her daughter
Trixie still being mortal.
And I talk more about that, and other predictions
for the show's final seasons, in my theories
video.
Click here for that or follow the link in
the video description.
If you enjoyed this video, then a thumbs-up
is hugely appreciated.
Tap left for my full Lucifer playlist with
videos on all the easter eggs you missed in
Season 5,
my Part 1 ending video with an explanation
of what to expect from God in Part 2,
and cool secrets about the making of the show.
Or tap right for something else you're sure
to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!